at one point during my playthrough a
fast and furious style streetracer Need
for Speed I hit a wall metaphorically
I've been building my stock subaru into
an unstoppable tuner beast for nearly 15
hours at that point but for whatever
reason I just could not get past the
most recently unlocked story missions I
tried and retried until I finally
decided to just grind through some
smaller side events to earn rep in hopes
of just upgrading my way to victory I
did eventually conquer those missions
and in the process I learned two
extremely valuable lessons one using a
single balanced ride to both drift and
race is an extremely terrible idea at
higher levels and two despite all of the
frustrating nonsense Need for Speed put
me through I was always excited to dive
back in
I thought sure you would get busted back
there it was nuts the game is far from
perfect but what it does well it does
exceptionally well it's jaw-dropping
visuals and adrenaline-pumping audio and
highly customizable handling makes
screaming around the darkened streets of
Ventura Bay and intense thrill and these
sense of ownership that comes from
tuning a single ride to perfection
rather than simply grabbing the
flashiest vehicle proved tremendously
rewarding this foundation of gratifying
gameplay anchors the experience while
the rest of Need for Speed specifics run
the gamut from equally outstanding to
utterly painful
take the goofy yet endearing narrative
the live-action cutscenes contained hit
after hit of stilted acting awkward
dialogue and unwarranted fist bumps
without advancing anything resembling a
plot and yet this crew of misfit racers
actually grew on me by the end I had
wholeheartedly embraced their warm
friendly corniness nineties yeah the
game world fairs slightly worse but
still holds up to scrutiny Need for
Speed is set in a completely open world
populated with events you can tackle in
any order along with hilly switchbacks
tangled highways and tight urban
corridors I somehow found myself in a
few of the same areas over and over
again but the level of detail variety
and overall believability made the city
in immersive high-speed playgrounds
even with its suspiciously sparse
traffic and perpetually rain slick
streets need for speeds roster of
vehicles includes the usual mix of
Lamborghinis Porsches and Ferraris but
you'll spend most of the campaign
gradually unlocking better components
and aesthetic upgrades for your less
exotic tutor mobile visually your
options are robust change the color
design a livery add an aftermarket
spoiler if you can picture it you can
usually create it which makes standing
out online fun and easy components like
engine blocks and suspension systems on
the other hand are slightly less
impressive generally the more expensive
the part the better your car will run so
if you want to upgrade your ignition for
example you just hunt for whatever part
you both unlocked and can't afford
there's really no strategy to it which
makes the whole process feel rote
fortunately buying these components also
grant you increasingly granular control
over your cars handling you'll
eventually open up sixteen different
sliders to control everything from tire
pressure ative shock stiffness and
believe it or not I could actually feel
the impact of every adjustment to put it
modestly it's an impressive system
fine-tuning my rides handling became a
kind of game consuming obsession but one
with very tangible rewards
however this obsession eventually got me
into trouble
need for speed features a wide variety
of events including point-based drift
competitions traditional circle races
and even Gymkhana events this mix
created a welcome gameplay variety but
it also led to that wall I eventually
smashed into early on my limited
resources forced me to pour all of my
efforts into a single vehicle by the
time I got to later more challenging
missions it didn't even occur to me that
my well-rounded ride was actually a
liability and the game provided no
feedback to indicate that a more drift
tuned car would immediately resolve my
problems that solution sounds super
obvious in retrospect but other points
of frustration were a bit more
inescapable for example Need for Speed
uses obvious rubber bands to keep
opponents within striking distance
during races having your competition
nipping at your heels creates tension
sure but allowing the AI to
automatically catch players cheapens the
upgrade system and can lead to
undeserved losses the drifting point
system is also needlessly punishing if
you so much as tap an obstacle at the
end of a drift you instantly lose any
points you might have received to that
drift it's infuriating thankfully if you
persevere you'll be left with a garage
full of tricked-out cars and a world
populated by friends to race with cops
to run from and leaderboards to top I
noticed a very small but forgivable
handful of framerate issues during my
playtime on the ps4 and the games always
online setup meant I could never truly
pause the game but none of that was
enough to detract from Need for Speed
stunning world and exhilarating driving
mechanics your move in diesel
you